you know I study mechanical engineering
in school I ended up becoming a
journalist I could name a dozen people
right now that I think are amazing
people who didn't go to college hi I'm
Tim Cavanaugh a reason TV we're here
with mark frauenfelder editor-in-chief
of make magazine and one of the founders
of boing boing the legendary website
mark great to see you yeah thanks Kim we
spoke with you a few years ago we're
just following up on a couple of things
one of them being that the current issue
of make has a pretty interesting section
on DIY super humanism a way of kind of
modifying your human capabilities
through gadgets the idea was that
there's new technologies out there that
are inexpensive for people to kind of
augment their their senses for example
we have one called the air guitar hero
is a project initially developed by some
medical researchers who wanted there was
this guy who lost his arm in the war and
he wanted to continue to play guitar
hero so they attached electrodes to his
arm the remaining part of his arm and
you know if you flex your muscles it
creates a small electrical signal and so
it by attaching electrodes and then
attaching that to another box that
processes the signals you can actually
play guitar hero just by kind of moving
your muscles and you can compress the
buttons and so we show how to do that at
home people can make that kind of thing
so you can play basically any video game
without using your fingers and it's kind
of an interesting way to learn how to
use those kind of electronics and this
is kind of stuff that although the war
has unfortunately produced a lot of
people who have missing limbs and parts
of lint it's the kind of thing that if
you were waiting for a you know a big
company to make this for you it would
never happen it's what they used to call
orphan medications right we're not
enough people have the situation to
really justify it but this is something
where it was done at a much smaller
level yeah definitely and a lot of this
stuff would take forever to get
clearance I'm sure you know be really
expensive for the testing and everything
like that but you can get this stuff now
is so inexpensive
we and with things like Arduino it makes
it really easy to do prototype
development Arduino is basically a
little circuit board with some
components on it that allow you to kind
of replicate any imaginable electronic
circuit easily through software and it
was basically created for artists and
designers to add interactivity to their
projects but people are using it to you
know control heart valves and things
like that it's a great tool another
couple of really cool things we have in
there one it's called the north paw is
that a bracelet that you wear around
your ankle and it has eight cell phone
vibrator motors around the circle and
then a an electronic compass and so you
can set it so you say i want to go to
you know a certain place it's got GPS n
it also so you want to go you know to a
certain library in it in an unfamiliar
town the little vibrators around well
tell you where to go and guide you there
is great for people who have a horrible
sense of direction like me like I get
lost walking out of my my bedroom now
we're only talking about gadgets here
and we should mention that this is a DIY
stuff and there are explanations in this
issue about how to hack the system
yourself how does this change the the
economic relations that we might have
had where you know in the past if I
wanted to get a prosthesis or something
like that I would have to just go to a
company and pay what they want me to pay
these people and make just do this stuff
for fun and for the kind of the ego boo
which is an old science fiction fandom
term that's been around since the 40s
it's like the unity the boost you get in
reputation by coming up with a cool hack
and also I think just a power of the
internet being able to collaborate on
things so they do have open source
prosthetic sites where people are
working on you know artificial arms and
legs and and they get to rapidly try
things out that a large research
institution might not be able to just
because of sheer inertia or you know
they get funding from someone who says
well we really want you to use this you
know carbon fiber material because if
you use that then we'll make a lot of
money and so by allowing kind of
outsiders to work on this stuff the
people who have a personal interest in
the successful outcome money becomes
not as important of course there are a
lot of people who make money in
open-source electronics and gadget Ritu
so there's markets there last time we
talked you and Ted Balor talked quite a
bit about unschooling and you want to
just give a quick precis of what that is
and then yeah so unschooling is the idea
that you don't send your kids to school
and you don't homeschool them either
rather what you do is you just let them
follow their own interests and kind of
encourage them but stay out of the way
most of the time there's so much to be
gained from education outside of school
I really don't have a lot of faith in
public schools being able to educate
kids in the way that they should be
educated today and so things like hacker
spaces or things that like make is
trying to do like the young makers
program or maker spaces where it's
after-school and weekend programs where
there are di wires who are just so
jazzed about doing all this that they
want to show other people kids and
adults how to learn by making and using
their hands that's kind of growing up
it's really taking off in a big way what
do you think of Peter Thiel's Thiel
fellowship where he pays you and this is
at the college level and most of the
damage is already done by the time here
in college but it was an interesting
proposal that was in immensely
controversial i mean the the
establishment really shook the
foundations once they heard about this
and it was denounced in Slate and the
New York Times and so forth but the idea
is that you're you're saying a college
is just a big waste of your time and
money and you'd probably be better off
doing something else and we will give
you the same benefit a scholarship type
of arrangement so that you will follow
your bliss in another way I think
there's there's merit in that idea I
could name a dozen people right now that
I that I respect and think are amazing
people who didn't go to college and so I
don't know if it's really that that
necessary you know I studied mechanical
engineering in school and I ended up
becoming a journalist and I you know
when I was going to school they didn't
have any
didn't have even know about the world
wide web or anything and that's how I
make my living now so I think for so
many people what they end up doing had
very little to do with what they learned
in college you know the socialization
aspect and getting your Yaya's out might
be the number one reason for going to
college sure what about the the argument
that nobody ever wants to admit that a
lot of school is just teaching kids how
to put up with crap like and I am NOT
not saying that as a joke really that
you you know that what whether we like
it or not they're going to be these
bureaucracies you have to negotiate
they're going to be forms you're always
filling out all the kind of thing this
is the place to store them still that
discipline yeah well I think you'll
learn that in the real world in a more
realistic way we should mention this is
a print magazine Eiffel days ago went
out and fought it it was fun and it was
sort of fun in the way of what going to
Colonial Williamsburg and churning your
own butter what is it like to be putting
out and we put out our own print
magazine I just want to you know it's
it's interesting to talk to somebody
who's in charge of getting a print
magazine out there in a for-profit
universe and all that kind of thing
where are we headed well it's a
challenge you know I mean uh barnes and
nobles shut down or yeah our borders and
reporter shut down God and that affected
our newsstand sales and so it's it's
tough we have to think how much longer
can we do print magazine I love the way
this magazine looks you know it's an
homage to the old popular science and
popular mechanics because of the size of
it and everything and a lot of readers
love the print version because it's you
know they can just pop it open on the
workbench and stuff you know magazines
right now as they are can be replicated
digitally very easily you can get the
whole experience of a magazine and put
it into an iPad or something and so the
idea is to get to come up with something
that is impossible to recreate digitally
and I think this this Japanese idea of
these these kind of magazines that come
with something cool so this is a
magazine that is also an ornithopter kit
yeah and so then it has all sorts of
stuff about you know fly Aidan and other
projects in there if we want to survive
in the print world this is something
that we need to start doing is is
attaching a kit to the magazine then
that way you can't copy it online are we
moving into a world where it's going to
be harder to slack off because you know
you have a japanese book there where i
could make in my own ornithopter if only
i read japanese and yet i can read
japanese because all i have to do is
take a phone and put it over the pages
and read the translation I mean there
are a lot of things you can do now I
think people have to train themselves to
to schedule their time and not get
overwhelmed by all that I think it is
important for people to learn to unplug
for a while and go for some analog R&R